let's go next to adam from knoxville
tennessee adam welcome sir
hey david great to talk to you sir my
pleasure
hey i have a quick question about the
the raid on mar-a-lago sure
are we gonna get like a press release
from the fbi kind of detailing exactly
what the evidentiary basis was for the
raid i have absolutely no idea i have
absolutely no idea it um i mean listen
it's not a requirement that the fbi do
that
sometimes the fbi on prominent cases
will brief the public as of this
recording of you know you and me talking
now that has not been done i'm very
interested in knowing whether they
looked very strongly at elements of
bathrooms during the raid and it's just
not something that they're telling us so
i want more information
but honestly and and by the way listen
donald trump can release the search
warrant as well i know lara trump went
on fox news and said he doesn't have it
well he might not physically have it but
his lawyers obviously do he can release
the search warrant at any time to prove
how bogus it all was he's not chosen to
do that
yeah right and i you know i have some
friends on the right and i'm i'm a
little concerned
that the basis wasn't super strong
really like from an optics or political
standpoint the right is going to use it
as like kind of a
like a martyr dumb for trump well of
course i mean they're going to do that
no matter what they've they've already
been saying he's the biggest victim of
anybody ever you know all this different
stuff that so that's i
where i agree they will say that either
way
where i agree with you adam is it would
be really bad
if there was not a strong evidentiary
basis for this and so
i am
giving the benefit of the doubt that if
the attorney general signed off on this
the fbi director signed off on it a
judge signed off on it
until proven otherwise i'm going to
assume that it was all done correctly
but if that's not the case i'll be the
first one here telling you that was not
done right
yep
perfect thank you can i ask you a quick
um cultural question sure follow-up
are you a fan of astra piazzolla
yeah yeah i mean in a casual sense i'm
not like a connoisseur of his music for
people wondering piazzolla was a very
very well-known
uh argentinian tango singer
and i don't know when do you know
offhand when he died how long has he he
been not around
no it's been a while he played was he a
singer i thought he was more of he
played the bendignon um oh my god is
that even a singer
you may be right he may not even have
been a singer but yeah i'm i'm a fan of
argentinian tango it's sort of in my
blood as they say
yeah astropiazzola is one of my favorite
musicians of all time so beautiful all
right well adam you sound like a man of
culture i appreciate it
thank you david thanks for the time adam
from knoxville very very strongly
participating in today's show you love
to hear it